on the bound for the oklahoma's is cole
irvin
cole irvin is gonna have to have an
outing like he did in his last start
against the san francisco giants where
he threw eight innings
absolutely kept him off balance and he's
gonna have his work cut out for him he's
gonna have to throw that change up he's
gonna have to get inside once in a while
and he's gonna have to keep the tempo
because these boston red sox hitters can
flat out swinging
grounds one to deep short and andrew is
from short left field we'll get it there
in time to retire [ __ ] hernandez
still getting it done the veteran at
shortstop for the athletics yeah he
mentioned the over shift a nice play by
anders he gets over there sets his feet
makes a good strong throw easily getting
hernandez but a nice way to start the
game getting that ground ball out
grounds this one by the mount softly
tony kemp will have time and he gets it
there just in time for out number two
on the ground to short elvis andrews is
there
and it's a one two three first for cole
irvin
athletics are coming up from oakland
it's on the bound today for the red sox
is garrett richard
you know he's going to have to throw
better than he did in his last start now
if you look at the accumulation of the
last start it was okay but he got
battered around early gave up some home
runs and
like alex cora is looking for some
consistency his last three starts he's
giving up a minimum of five runs in each
of those looking for better tonight here
against oklahoma
and here's a pop fly right side out to
the outfield grasses hernandez fires to
first and that's two
they turn it into a double play
[ __ ] hernandez ducking back to the short
lawn in right to reel it in and he fires
to dalbeck at first and they double off
andrews
[Applause]
and he will take strike three down the
inning so tough start for richards he
pitches his way in and out of trouble
picks up his first k of the night
one and two one out bonded with a second
no score
swings at the 1-2 and diving at third
base is davis from one knee throws him
out
raphael davis with a great play at third
base
from one knee made a great throw to get
lorianno well you see him range to his
left and then just rolls but he throws
for one knee i mean that the arm
strength there he runs batted in for the
oklahoma's catcher and swing it away
here hops on up into shallow center out
to dive to make the bid with hernandez
but it's out of his reach
just out of the reach of [ __ ] hernandez
pretty good bid though
as murphy will reach with a two out
bloop single
driven to center field santana going
back and won't get it it's by him to the
track of the wall
murphy's coming around
he will score heading to third base is
brown he'll get there
it's a triple and an rbi and it's the
openness who strike first on top one to
nothing
just out of the reach of danny santana
this pitch just up in the zone and
brown
hammers a sick just
out of the outstretched glove of santana
murphy easily able to score brown was
moving too
and here come the red sox threatening
with two on and one out for hunter
renfrow
this one is thrown away down the right
field line and goguards is going to be
waved around he will score the
game-tying run
javers to third will be safe
just a tough throw for olson to handle
going into foul territory
as debras was well off the bag
1-1 game here in the fourth
it's tied this game one-to-one rafael
denver's 90 feet away so the infield is
in all the way around right now for the
a's and a 2-2 pitch is coming to hunter
renfro
fly ball center field lorianno going
back onto the warning track to make the
catch in front of the wall
jogging holm as he tags up and scores is
rafael devers
2-1 red sox on top thanks for the sac
fly by hunter renfrow
so two down hernandez at second base and
jd martinez
driven to left field and in for a base
hit for jd martinez here comes [ __ ]
hernandez around and the red sox add on
to their lead on top 3-1
jd martinez gathers his 56th rbi of the
year
martinez just gets his ball up in the
zone and able to fire this thing out the
left look you don't have a lot of wiggle
room when you're out on the mound you've
got
martinez and bogart's endeavors
matt chapman lines one into center field
to start things here in the sixth inning
here in the bottom of the sixth inning
for the athletics and frank schwindl
coming up here
liner down the left field line to the
left field corner matt chapman is headed
around towards there they're gonna wave
him around he will score
it's an rbi double for swindle and it's
a one-run game red sox have a 3-2 lead
but the a's making some noise here in
the sixth inning
[Applause]
in the air to left field that goes jd
martinez you'll have room
and he'll make the catch running behind
him with santana and the throwback into
the infield two down so two down and jed
lowry is going to pinch in
one already tonight two-and-oh the pitch
swinging a chopper back over the mound
bogart's to his left behind the bag
gloves and throws to first in time to
get lowry what a play walk twice says
and grounded to short
see swings and drives one high and deep
into left field way back there it is
gone
that was it he was thinking about it and
he did it kiki's tenth home run pads the
lead it's four two red sox
[Applause]
1-0 is lying towards right center field
that's going to get down
remember to play it is santana her
bobble out there
it's first and third with two down in
the inning now for the athletics first
and third two down in the a seventh
inning
swinging a miss and he struck him out
they'll strand two
brown his triple popped out and fly to
left 4-2 boston one out one on bottom of
the eighth
drilled to right center renfro going
back in the alley it's over his head and
off the very top of the wall murphy's at
third they're gonna wave him he's coming
around third and there'll be no throw as
the throat comes in and dies on the
infield and now it's a four to three
lead for boston first and third for the
athletics two down elvis andrews yet a
base hit his last time up 2-2 piston
elvis is swung on line to right-center
table again and kept around second going
to third he is have runners at first and
third elvis comes through once again
the beer snake is now mobile it's making
its way around
that's outstanding bottom of the ninth
inning
chapman at second base and murphy
murphy hits it on the ground to third
devers with a bobble throw to first will
be
in time still got him
[Applause]
taking off for third swinging a miss
throw down to third base he is ouch
pot trying to steal his santana for out
number two of the tenth
and a swing of the miss
well let's go to work here
the bunt bit is a pop-up that is caught
and now it's up to elvis the pitch
swinging a line drive into left field jd
catches it tagging it third is murphy
the throw tag out at the plate again
and for the second straight night in the
10th inning the red sox throw out murphy
at home plate
second and third with two down ramon
laureato
fly ball to left field moving over is
martinez he will make the catch and we
will go to the 12th inning
i mean heck for the the health of those
people out there
the gays have got to score when gonzalez
walked in the ninth inning with first
and third and one out
this is to left field and that is in for
a base hit from third base to score as
rafael devers and the red sox take a 5-4
lead in the 12th inning what's up [ __ ]
and two here's the pitch swinging a line
drive over the head of the leaping lowry
into right field to base it vasquez
comes home he scores it's six for red
sox seth brown he is the winning run
line to right that's in for a base hit
lorianno
is coming around from second he will
score and the tying run goes to third
base first in third jed lowry
fly ball headed to left field and deep
back goes martinez still going and he's
not going to get it it's going to win up
the wall
incoming is murphy brown will be stopped
at third base and it's second and third
with a tie game now kemp a chance to win
it
swung on fly balls shallow center no
going back on it is hernandez going back
it's pretty deep he'll make the catch
here comes brown here comes the throw
it's not in time and the a's have
survived and they've beaten the red sox
7-6